Hey folks, happy Wednesday or Sunday or whichever
day it is you’re watching this.
I figure instead of spending days engineering
the perfect 15 minute video script while I
could be spending time with my family, I’m
just gonna spend five minutes shamelessly
riffing on a concept brought up in my comment
section, that being slot compression.
The idea of slot compression is basically
this—you can fit more stuff into your deck,
more things of each category like finishers
or draw or removal, if you pick out and play
cards that can do multiple things.
For midrange decks, an easy way to do slot
compression is to run decently-statted creatures
that do other things your deck wants to do.
In a dirt cheap Rakdos deck I built a while
back, the creature count is decently high,
but the vast majority of the creatures in
the deck either draw me cards or make my opponents
discard cards.
Even among the more finisher-oriented cards
that don’t fit into these two categories,
most are blood artist effects, which perform
a secondary duty of discouraging board wipes,
so the compression is still there.
My Glissa deck is a more high-curved example
of this principle.
Fun fact—if you pay a lot of mana for a
creature, it will often be great for multiple
things.
My deck caches in a hefty 20 or so slots up
front for ramp, but it is rewarded for this
with a creature base consisting of powerful
removal and draw spells stapled to 5/5s and
8/8s and 10/10s, which means that the deck
ends up being able to win games without a
single dedicated wincon slot.
Another example of this is hate bears decks.
By running stax effects that are also creatures,
these decks are able to heavily oppress their
opponents’ game plans, while still having
a boardstate to block and pressure life totals.
Sometimes this pressure will be pivotal to
winning, such as in my Liesa deck, and other
times it will serve more as an alternative
wincon or as hate toward lifepay, but regardless
this flexibility is very useful.
For more combo-oriented decks, one way to
have plenty of space for both pieces and supporting
cards is to pick cards that do both.
If you need a sac outlet for your combo, you’ll
naturally run into the issue that some games
you won’t draw one and other games you’ll
draw multiple.
You could run only a couple and some tutors,
but you could also run a bunch of altars in
a deck with artifact synergies, or sac outlets
that get buffed if you want an alternative
beatdown wincon, or cards like Fanatical Devotion
and Greater Good, which might just be generically
good cards in some decks.
There are also combo decks looking for a lot
of certain types of cards to go off, such
as with a mid-power Najeela deck.
There, a reasonable plan might be throwing
in low-cost warriors you like from any color,
which will further the beats and combo potential
offered by the commander while also letting
you have high quality creatures.
The general gist here is that if you can make
cards needed for your combo also be valuable
in their own right in the deck, the combo
will feel much less space-gobbling.
This logic also applies for heavily synergistic
decks.
If you have a deck focusing on a particular
card type such as equipments or auras, having
a lot of your supporting cards also fit into
those types means that your wincons will pack
a ton of power, and it will also have the
added benefit that conditional tutors will
give you access to a good portion of your
deck.
The same goes for decks that focus on particular
creature types or particular attributes—if
you’re building a Goreclaw deck and your
deck’s draw and removal mostly consists
of creatures with power 4 or greater, suddenly
you can fit a whole lot more beef into the
deck while still having it feel smooth and
well-rounded.
Finally, let’s talk lands.
MDFCs, utility lands, and other dual mode
cards that get you lands are great, and I
highly encourage using these.
I sometimes see people run land counts in
the low 30s in decks that aren’t that low-curved,
and while I appreciate the desire to draw
gas, I echo Interesting_Failure’s thinking
here: at least do your future self a favor
and throw in some MDFCs or utility lands to
bring your count up to 35 or 36.
This goes for high-curved decks running 36
lands as well—don’t be afraid to MDFC
your way up to 38 or 39, or even… break
into the 40s, ooooh.
I plan to do a longer video about lands and
manabases sometime soon so I’ll save further
discussion of the subject until then, but
long story short—lands are good, and people
often don’t play enough of them in casual
EDH.
I’ve discussed some different ways to “compact
your slots”, you know, to run cards that
satisfy multiple things your deck wants, and
I think a logical question to ask regarding
this is “exactly how valuable is it to have
compacted slots?”
I like to think I have laid out a decent case
for doing such a thing—you can run more
of each supporting type of card while still
maintaining a solid core to your deck, and
you can also run a higher land count for purposes
of not getting screwed while mitigating some
of the downsides of mana flood.
However, an important thing to remember is
this—at its core, your deck still needs
to do a thing that wins.
In the past I’ve sometimes fallen deep into
the hole of synergy and support cards, and
built a deck that runs very smoothly and feels
good at the table, but ultimately lacks substantive
wincons and usually just succumbs to getting
outscaled by somebody else.
I advocate for people to put more support
cards in their decks because I think the average
EDH player is on the opposite end of the snappy-to-smooth
spectrum as me, but it’s good to keep in
the back of your head that playing smoothly
and having interaction isn’t a substitute
for having a good way to end the game—you
should try to have both of these things in
your deck.